-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-Very exciting.
We have
two of the funniest people
who ever made
some of the bestest
and funniest movies ever,
and one of them
just directed the other
in the new HBO documentary,
"Albert Brooks:
Defending My Life."
Please welcome
Albert Brooks and Rob Reiner.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-♪ (UPBEAT ROCK PLAYING) ♪
(INDISTINCT CHATTER)
-There's the Sunshine Boys.
-Hey, Bill!
How are you?
-Good. How are you?
-How are you?
You're looking very svelte.
-Thank you.
-Fellas, I'm...
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪
-I'm so kvelt or whatever the--
-ALBERT BROOKS: Kvelt?
-No? (LAUGHS)
-That's not a Jewish word.
-There's no Jewish--
-I know. I know.
-It's kvelling, you're kvelling.
-Kvelling, that's what I use.
-Yeah, you're not--
-Kvelt is a hospital word,
it's "four months to live."
-BILL MAHER: I see. (LAUGHS)
-(GUESTS LAUGH)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: All right.
ALBERT:
"Patient in 208 is kvelt."
-I mean--
-(BOTH LAUGH)
But it's been a--
I mean, I've wanted you here
for the longest time.
You, I don't get to see enough,
but it's always a pleasure
when you're here.
Thank you for bringing him,
for doing this.
(SCOFFS) What am I, a dog?
-(GUESTS LAUGH)
-(LAUGHS)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
He's my service animal.
-BILL: Okay. And I--
-Fun to look out the window!
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I always knew you guys
were friends
until I saw this documentary.
I didn't know--
I know you went back.
I didn't know, what--
You go way, way back.
Yes, to high school. Yes.
-High school, is that how you--
-We met in high school, yes.
BILL: Oh, my God.
Yeah, and we became
instant friends.
We met-- It was a class.
I think we were like 16, 17
at the time-- Sixteen!
-It was-- It remains...
-(CLEARS THROAT)
...one of the most
embarrassing moments of my life
-because...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
So, it was a class,
the first day you stand up,
-you introduce yourself.
-BILL: Hmm.
Now, I was given the name,
"Albert Einstein..."
-BILL: Yes.
-...and still using it
-at the time.
-BILL: Oh, really?
Except I didn't like it
in high school.
I had to use "Al"
because I didn't want people
-to, you know-- One--
-ROB REINER: Confuse him
-with the guy who--
-That's right. I mean, I...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
You know,
people would say, you know,
why did they name me
Albert Einstein?
Well, Jesus Christ was taken.
That was my answer.
-(ROB LAUGHS)
-(CHUCKLES)
-So...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
So, I stood up and I said,
"My name is Al Einstein,
I'm from Los Angeles."
And Rob's way in the back,
and then 40 other people,
and then he stands up
in the back and I don't--
I just hear "Rob from New York,"
I never heard any last name.
So, after the class,
I choose to come up to him.
"You're from New York, huh?"
Now, two weeks earlier,
I went to a museum
of broadcasting,
just because I loved it,
and I met Carl Reiner.
-BILL: Hmm.
-I shook his hand.
I said to him,
"So, what are you doing
from New York?
What does your dad do?"
Rob goes, "He's a writer."
I don't know why, Bill,
but I said,
"I know Carl Reiner."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-ALBERT: And--
-(CHUCKLES)
And I said, "So do I."
-Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-BILL: Oh.
-(ALBERT CHUCKLES)
And he said, "That's my dad."
And I said, "I'm a stupid fuck."
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But your dad thought
he was like the funniest kid.
-Even-- I--
-ROB: Yes.
Not just the funniest kid.
He thought
he was the funniest person--
I mean, Albert at 16
was a prodigy.
He could make my dad,
Mel Brooks,
-people of the highest level...
-BILL: Yeah--
...in comedy, make them laugh.
So, I heard that
in the documentary,
and I'm curious
if you could give me
one instance of that,
that I can picture
a 16-year-old--
What did you say?
What did you do that made
these comedy lions laugh?
Well, I did a bit once
for him and Mel
-and a lot of other comedians.
-BILL: A bit?
-A bit.
-Yeah, well, he came--
I would come over to their house
-and do bits.
-He came up with a--
-BILL: Really?
-On the top of his head.
He didn't plan it,
and he just came up and he said,
"You know, I've got this thing.
I'm the greatest escape artist
in the world.
I can get out of anything."
And so we took a napkin,
and he says, "Tie my hands up."
And I draped the napkin
over his hands.
He said, "That's good enough.
I can't get out of that.
-I can't get out of that."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And then he took a tissue
and he stuffed it in his mouth.
And he said, "Okay."
And then he went
behind a curtain, and he said
he was gonna get out
from behind a curtain
with this, and we hear
from behind the curtain,
it's rustling.
We're hearing, "I can't breathe!
I can't breathe!
-I can't breathe! Open the--"
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
We open the curtain
and he flies out.
He says, "Take it out!
Take it out! Untie me!"
And we untied him, and my father
was screaming hysterically.
-The worst escape artist.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
BILL: So, you...
-So, you were--
-Not bad for 15.
BILL:
No, I-- Amazing, I mean...
Yeah, no, no.
He was a genius and is a genius.
Right. Right. And wound up
doing your stand-up career
the same way,
even on television. Right?
Not really thinking about it
before you--
Well, I would work it out
by myself at home.
-BILL: Right.
-And then I would go down
and I would do
national television.
I never went to a club.
-Ever.
-BILL: Right
Until I had done, like,
five years
of national television.
-ROB: Yeah. It was amazing.
-So, I never tried out anything.
And it was fine. It worked out.
Yeah, I mean, Chris Rock says
in the documentary, he says,
the idea of somebody
going on national television
and not even trying it out,
not even seeing
if it would work,
That's what he did.
He did it all the time.
He went on Carson 30 times.
And he just tried up new stuff.
And so, by the time
you graduated high school,
you were fast friends.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
We'd do summer stock together.
And then what was the--
I'm curious about the time,
like, before you were married,
when you were just two,
-you know?
-ROB: Well, we had a house.
-We had a house together.
-We roomed together
-after college.
-Yeah.
We have a house up in...
off Benedict Canyon.
It had two entrances.
There was one below
where Albert was
and then there was one above.
It was like a duplex.
We each had our own phones.
And whenever I brought
a girl over, you know,
we'd, you know, have our fun...
-in the bedroom.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
ALBERT: He means
he and the girl.
BILL: Yeah, I understand.
It's HBO. We can say anything.
We don't have to--
Yeah, no. We're in the--
We're having--
We're making love upstairs.
"Making love."
You can still say fuck.
-Okay, we fucked!
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
ROB: We fucked!
-BILL: Yeah.
-And...
And the minute we were done,
the phone would ring.
And I'd pick it up
and it would be Albert.
And he'd say,
"Are you finished yet?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And I'd say, "Yes."
-Now, let me tell you something.
-He said,
"Do you wanna
go get something to eat?"
-But let me tell you--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Let me tell you something.
And I hope you'll take this
as a compliment.
He was like the atomic clock
in Boulder.
-It was exactly 40 seconds.
-(CHUCKLES)
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
No, I mean, literally,
I used to boil an egg
to him fucking.
(CHUCKLES) Yeah, no, he'd hear
the noise has started,
-check his watch. He--
-Yeah. I'd call it 35 seconds.
He'd say,
"Give me four seconds."
-I mean, it was...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-It was amazing. So, you know.
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
If I'd roomed with someone
that took two hours,
-I'd probably be thinner.
-You'd starve.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. You'd starve to death.